à
[Musique]
être apprenti on l'a vu c'est souvent
faire le choix de métiers qui ont besoin
de les photos et c'est particulièrement
vrai en boulangerie quand il faut que
peint et croissant soit frais alors du
petit déj patron il est là depuis une
heure et une mode et voilà deux heures
aujourd'hui des journées d'été fois il
arrive à 00h30 être à nouveau fait seuls
nous regarder nous souffler en arrivant
2 heures du matin
35 heures vous ça vous dit
si tous les deux jours le cursus de
julien et particuliers à 23 ans il s'est
relancé en apprentissage après un
parcours plutôt atypique
en fait je sortais d'un lycée militaire
et donc je suis arrivée à la fac de
droit de lyon et en arrivant à la fac de
droit j'ai vite vu que ça allait pas me
convenir je suis arrivé en 2e année je
suis allé jusqu'à la fin je suis arrêté
j'ai trouvé un petit boulot en attendant
dans une dans une boulangerie justement
puis c'est là où je me suis dis bah
c'est quand même sympa c'est à ces
manuels
ça me plaît bien et puis bon bah j'ai
commencé à faire ma petite recherche
pour trouver un maître d'apprentissage
et une pierre c'est là qu'intervient
monsieur blanchard qui est quand même
m'a donné ma chance je serai j'étais
plus âgées comme beaucoup de gens qui
qui se voit là
quelqu'un de cet âge là on peut quand
même plus cher connais rien du tout à la
boulangerie attention ça va cracher fort
là je vous préviens plus que ça
tu as quand même donné ma chance et puis
au final va j'essaie de rendre le mieux
que je peux et je suis vraiment
reconnaissant c'est la rolls des
apprentis je vais pas demander mieux
c'est vraiment c'est quelqu'un qui qui
enregistre qui écoute qui met en
application ce qu'on lui ce qu'on lui
apprend donc je crois demander mieux les
apprentis d'un genre nouveau qui
bénéficie aujourd'hui d'une possibilité
d'entrer en apprentissage plus tard une
évolution de la vie professionnelle une
forte demande de reconversion voilà ce
qui est à l'origine de cette expérience
menée en ce moment en bourgogne franche
comté entrer en apprentissage jusqu'à
l'âge de 30 ans on a à faire à d'autres
publics
l'apprentissage jusqu'à 30 ans ça veut
dire que des gens qui se sont au départ
destiné à d'autres études nous viennent
un peu plus tardivement et on aura un
vrai projet de professionnels dont qui
se destine en fait à ouvrir des
entreprises pour être leur propre patron
et ils ont parfois 20 ans 23 ans après
avoir fait des études supérieures
ils n'ont pas d'employabilité
l'apprentissage nouvelle génération est
en marche et il semble qu'en
d'entreprise les mentalités est évolué
en même temps les patrons rossi en
changer
considère mieux les apprentis qu'avant
on essaie aussi de l'homme de vraiment
leur apprendre un métier nous non pas
seulement leur faire faire débat stage
ce qui ne change pas en revanche c'est
bien la fringale des écoliers sur le
coût des quatre heures ça aussi c'est
une des bases du métier que les élèves
vont apprendre à l'école je vais
chercher comme d'hab affaires conforme
pas trop pointu pour au port le petit la
petite qui vient son temps de l'école a
acheté sa petite baguette viennoise pour
le goûter
s'ils avaient des bons points sur le
projet de julien c'est d'ouvrir sa
propre boulangerie pourquoi pas dans un
village pourquoi pas une boulangerie bio
à moins qu'il ne choisisse de faire
encore une autre formation l'école en
propose dans une vingtaine de métiers et
de nouveau c'est la paix vont bientôt
être créée pour les facteurs conducteur
livreur par exemple ou encore dans le
secteur de l'oenologie